make all your content for strangers
everyone to a party and a bunch of
people are joking and then you're like
you walk into the circle and they sell
some inside joke and they're like you
had to be there and you're like okay you
want the opposite of that with your
content so if you're always making
content specifically for your audience
as in it references past content that a
new person wouldn't know about without
explaining what it means or giving the
context they're going to feel like the
odd man out what you want to do in my
opinion is make all your content for
someone who's brand new and people
who've already consumed your stuff are
okay with the few you know the hey by
the way if you're new to this channel
XYZ that's okay they're not going to
stop watching you as long as you're
still providing value but for the new
person who's walking in it can make all
the difference in the world the reason
you do this is it grows your audience
faster if you make them feel included